what is happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch the next episode of
brooklyn nine nine today if you can
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated thank you to all of and stay
with us on our journey by subscribing
and clicking that notification about
them handsome boys at prepper thank you
so much for helping us edit down these
highlights you can find the full length
watch alongs for b99 at our patreon
special thanks to all become superior
jacks by checking out all the crap we
got to offer over there 30 seconds we're
done
[Music]
gina hasn't taken her eyes off her phone
in two hours first person to make her
look up wins the pot i'm in i bet which
improves someone's manners double score
i used to have to distract her from the
phone all the time when we were
smooshing booties
that's your sister
[Music]
she's unbeatable oh i don't know about
that
terence jeffords are you kidding me
change my relationship status to it's
complicated pony up
terrible a call did you get me up there
it is oh
no
no no no no it was a mistake my thumb
slipped it
i have to go home
i better take that money with you i have
to go home
quality cold open
today is the greatest day of my life
guess who just got murdered
it's carl mather
what i'm the only one gasping guys carl
mather did 25 years of data
oh they stole 21 million from an armored
car depot feds caught them but they
never found the money until now you
found 21 million not yet i can see how
that would have been confusing though
i'm sorry but i'm going to
you don't know that mather's death is
connected to the money yet treat this
like a regular case sir with all due
respect this is an epic case it's the
reason i became a cop repelling out of a
chopper with a knife between my teeth
because both of my hands are holding
giant machine guns and that's how it's
going down
better see that my girls are on the
waitlist for their preschool and it's
twice as tough to get in with twins why
don't you just get one of them in and
then let them take turns going to school
every other day
i speak their language they are going to
have an amazing time thanks guys that's
great if you want i can show them some
of the cool stuff we have in the
evidence locker pretty sure there's a
bag of hands in there oh
quick update another one of the fulton
street four was murdered here this
morning huh i'm surprised you're not
celebrating inappropriately this is a
crime scene and i'm a professional you
did it before i showed up yeah that is
exactly correct
in the past two days it has to be tied
to the missing money admit i was right
circumstances do suggest a connection
admit it with more gusto you were right
oh the camera was in selfie mode but i
look super proud of you okay
cheese skunk madeline lunch has her
hindquarters pointed right at it no
doubt to give the case the major crimes
no no no we can't let that happen sir we
have to do something fine i'll seduce
her i'll just put on my bike shorts and
give her a glimpse of the quad cities no
no do it
treat the devil and you don't dance with
the devil because you get burned
this is my desk
you can tell by the framed 200 piece
puzzle my three-year-olds put together
on their own that's very advanced
sergeant jeffords is it
i wouldn't know what milestones are
impressive to a school admissions
officer
huh they can count to 20 in english from
mandarin hi detective santiago magnet
school alumna well i appreciate that you
use the proper declension of alumnus
well some say latin is a dead language
but i say it's just taking a long nap
that's right amy
you two are obviously the alphas let me
guess
you're dating the blonde kid and you
like filipino beaver but you're worried
how did you know
i know so much
hi i'm gina
hey
everyone's aunt gina how do you like my
new office 20th floor yes i never
thought i'd see you this high without a
broom under you
i'm not sure the 99 has the resources to
deal with something of this magnitude
since you don't have the resources i'll
give you anything you need the case is
yours you have my full support what he
meant that more excited like
what's going on here my hunch one of
them is killing off his coast gum so he
can keep the money for his scum self
we'll start with reggie bledsoe he
listed a brooklyn address with his
parole officer we're gonna nail this son
of a [ __ ] unless he's innocent then
we're gonna save the son of a [ __ ]
wunch is up to something there's only
one reason why she would let us keep
this case she took one look at me and
said that's the guy i want fly in my
chopper oh you know how to fly a chopper
how hard are you gonna be it's just a
big fan that goes in the sky
because she wants us to fail i'm coming
along so that you don't waste time and
resources turning this investigation
into another ron mclean movie you know
it's john mcclane
[Laughter]
knocker toby pleasure i signed out that
drug dealer's lamborghini from the
impound it only has two seats i saw that
you had made that request i changed it
to a sensible sedan okay but the sunroof
stays open there is no sunroof no
thanks for warming her up santiago they
didn't give eighth grade amy the key to
the teacher's lounge just for nothing
stocked their fridge and cleaned up
after them oh go over with the kids for
a minute they're done with this activity
of course i am amazing with kids
oh
who here would like to see a
presentation about crime statistics as a
function of demographics and time
show them the body a picture of a dead
body
classic
i would have preferred an abandoned
lighthouse or a dilapidated barn but i
can embellish in my memoirs oh i can't
wait to read that book what are you
gonna call it
go ahead jake my day
case closed jake open wow i know i said
yours was better
wait
don't close that look handprint that's a
fake wall
nypd
come out with your hands on your head
don't shoot don't shoot he's trying to
kill me kids work well your daughters
sound great
you know i'm gonna look over their
applications again oh no that's not
necessary shepherds were too office
smooth amazing experience here today
oh no
roses sarge is here oh my god
children get out of this room
immediately let's go
no
i was walking home from the coffee shop
i have a job busting tables there anyway
the next thing i know mikey d has a gun
in my back michael d'angelo the other
member of the fulton street four yes
believe it or not i familiarize myself
with the names of all two suspects
[Laughter]
crack detective work
and what's in the safe the 21 million
bing pots nope i was gonna say bingo but
then i was like jackpot's better but
then it was too late i was halfway
through the word bing pot works it's
taking off pink putt okay they're gonna
have to raid the place without us it'll
take us two hours to get up there or we
could we are not taking a helicopter you
know i was gonna say chopper
it's the kind of thing she'll crucify me
for not getting you could've had a
chopper raymond why did you take
advantage just a minute my cauldron's
boiling over yeah
[Laughter]
she may have called me and i may have
briefed her and she may have said yes to
the chopper because it's definitely on
its way right now i call middle c what
have you done let's do it
to the chopper
okay just so we're clear from this point
forward my call sign will be death blade
and i'll be rum tum tugger
angelico boyle adopt hitler no
hello
dr sussman i am so so sorry please don't
hold this against my daughters i would
never do that look our methods may have
been a little unorthodox and perhaps a
little graphic and disgusting
traumatizing these kids had fun today
and they learned a lot bobby what's a
nucleation it's when someone pops your
eyeball out probably should have used a
less gross example
[Laughter]
i got mckenzie and brianna to stop
hating on kelsey s and now they're best
friends you're welcome wow that's
actually impressive thank you
[Laughter]
it was interesting i saw a prostitute
not helping kids
you go take care of that kid terry tell
your man if they find the money first
that i get to riffle it next to my ear
and go it's all here i already told him
jake love you bud
[Laughter]
good partner right there
oh he's here
i can feel it
he is he's dead what
body is right here hey it's peralta is
bledsoe still in custody yeah we got him
man he's in his
oh come on
good news first we're gonna be flying
back past a beautiful sunset
he's pacing slowly for him that's like a
full-on rage fueled freak out the only
thing worse is when he stands perfectly
still
oh no he's standing perfectly still all
right i'm gonna go talk to him oh
no
sir we're tracking a triple murderer who
stole 21 million dollars and all you can
think about is madeline wuntch
you're right what's that now
can i get that in writing all i wanted
was the chance to do good police work
again i just got it
and i blew it
thinking about that devil toad
[Laughter]
let's get that punk blood so yeah why
would someone who knows they have 21
million coming take a minimum wage job
because he needed access to that
building because that's where the
money's hidden all right we got to get
there quick maybe we should take the
chopper
yes roger that wet blanket no from now
on call me
velvet
thunder
[Applause]
velvet
[Music]
all right listen up we go in strong and
we go in fast evans you're on door
breach patterson flashbang boyle stop
squatting like that
[Music]
nice
you didn't want me to fail
you wanted me to succeed that's right i
was looking for an excuse to promote you
to a desk job and you handed it to me on
a silver platter with your little rat
hands oh no no say goodbye to the
nine-nine ring no smile for the cameras
raymond that's your new job now
hey
okay quick let's pose back to back with
our arms crossed and a cocky smirk
you're doing it are your arms crossed
arms down that's good
no
holds no
damn it say it ain't so
damn it
all right john what personal life
problem we're working out today okay um
well i've never ridden in a helicopter
which i feel like you're [ __ ] i know
it is i i i've heard so many if you just
took a chance it could have been
too many excuses for why i haven't
ridden in one of the time or money to go
in a helicopter there's not one nearby
i'm standing in my own way
and i need to uh give myself that that's
right
and uh when you promoted me to that desk
job ah i dude i just want to be out
there in the [ __ ] man that's all i want
is to be out there
reacting
in the field
that was a clever twist on things man i
know that was a [ __ ] twist on things
yeah
freaking watch there's only one reason
she could want him to do a good job
sabotage
i like the lesson he learns about you
know because like jake keeps that
childlike wonder that bemusement of
being a cop that fantasy
alive the fun
whereas holt has been so caught up in
his ways that he hasn't
he can you know he's just he thinks
about other things instead of
remembering what it's like to just be a
cop and get the job done and
enjoy it too that motivation
put your expertise to the test which i
think i can relate to in some ways
you're a great cop
the best the best
dude you've cracked so many cases bro
you brought down so many perps i think
why is because like doing a gig like
this
in a lot of ways is like a dream job and
then uh often times you get so caught up
in the work and you're fixated on other
things and other people's opinions and
other people that it's like well wait a
minute
this is a pretty cool thing and i got to
just do that there i
made it personal that's really wonderful
i can relate to worried you just wear it
i feel like the
i feel like the hot sauce of these tanks
is personal lifestyle that's right man
we come here every week to laugh our
problems away and learn a little bit
about how we as people could be better
too like you like i mean i certainly
learned something about connecting with
kids i used to teach
improv to children and i was always
showing them dead bodies all the time if
i had been showing them dead bodies all
the time you know my classes might have
gone a lot smoother i'm usually showing
children dead bodies see you are the
gina to my every other character first
need you to enlighten me on things like
that so the next time i'm teaching kids
improv i can be like guys just come over
here
and look at these crime scene photos
whenever someone's like hey can you
watch my kid for a second or watch my
baby
i get a little frozen i'm a little
paralyzed what else to say
first thing i do go to my phone go to my
favorites
pull up some dead bodies that's right
man
got a special folder for him right at
the top right at the top so if anybody
gets into your phone you know they could
learn something they can they would know
right away yeah yeah that like i got a
big collection of dead bodies to to show
kids oh don't worry these aren't all my
dead bodies yeah some of them are mine
you only wet these out
yeah yeah they're therapeutic in a way
they remind you of mortality they give
you good perspective you could learn
something much like the kids in today's
episode did
i like the lesson of uh i like the
writing on this episode a lot of how you
know like peralta
wants to fulfill this action hero
fantasy
holt trying to like get rid of the
fantasy and be as realistic as possible
about this
and then ultimately when the situation
looks like it crumbles they kind of have
to
adopt the reality of the situation
which is like peralta being like no i
did this because i'm a cop and you're
too hung up on something that's not
important right now and then holt had to
realize that he needs to kind of embrace
a little bit of jake's mentality and
together through one becoming a little
bit more realistic about the situation
and honest and the other one embracing a
little bit more of the inspiration
that's what gets them to solve the case
together i think that's like pretty cool
yeah i love that little speech like that
was that was the time where i was
expecting some kind of
humor but it was like such a nice nifty
uh character beat for peralta to be like
no this this case itself is epic and i
really want to solve these circumstances
it's not even about the chopper but we
have access so why not you know yeah
yeah and uh
some just good good old character beats
all around now charles boyle we all
deserve a charles boyle in our life to
be selfieing our best moments
and uh he becomes a little too cartoony
for me sometimes yeah i mean he is uh
that is the easy way to go with that
character this is like the easiest okay
super dumb
when it counts
super super silly super fanboy over jake
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah something does
that joke that works after a while like
this joke it's like
becoming a little redundant
yeah it's it's sort of the point where
they're default when they don't know
what to do with them
yeah
it's just sometimes really even in this
episode sometimes it's really funny but
sometimes it's like okay i get it
with the memoir title i think that was
the best instance in this episode uh uh
oh what was it whoa whoa no
[ __ ]
jake cover no uh
yeah
jake
no that was case closed jake open
bad title
dang that's gonna tickle my brain
because it's on the tip of my tongue
damn it either way this is a great
episode guys thank you so much for being
here if you enjoyed this video please
leave a like subscribe click that bell
check us out on patreon and we will
catch you guys soon
when did daredevil show up to the review
it's my right foot
that is what that murdock
introduction i want in the mcu
i don't need the sight
look
i'm such a good lawyer you guys
daredevil brooklyn nine-nine crossover
hey it worked that's what we want
[Music]